I want to jump in with my other hat the
Rockefeller Foundation had if I can and
and respond to that when I talked about
21st century paradigms I really want to
emphasize that people need to think
about that because the world is shifting
and one of the interesting things that
we've seen in philanthropy is that we
you are right we are a very non
innovative sector there's been a huge
proliferation of NGOs there's been a
huge proliferation of foundations and
everybody comes from their own model and
pretty much their own expert sense of
what should be done and the way that it
should be done and we've been very
influenced by the innovation literature
that's developing and the kinds of
innovation practices and policies that
really been developed in the private
sector and and are now being thought
about and we're trying to systematically
at Rockefeller apply them to the social
sector environmental health and the like
and the three that we've been most
interested in have been crowdsourcing so
that not using the knowledge of the
crowd as opposed to that knowledge of
the experts design thinking which is a
new creative way of approaching problems
and user driven innovation and I just
want to give you a user-driven because
it really builds on on your point so
there's a wonderful NGO NGO positive
deviance and they go into communities
and villages all over the world
particularly in the developing world and
they try to determine what behaviors are
making some people succeed when
everybody else is failing why are some
people the positive deviance and what's
interesting is that there are all well
trained anthropologists so that they're
taking their skills their academic
skills as anthropologists to observe and
learn from what people are doing and my
favorite vignette and how we came to
know them because we do a lot of work in
Vietnam is they went into a village
Vietnam and they saw a couple of kids
who were really quite well nourished
against a background of desperate
malnutrition in the rest of the children
and so they observed the families and
the children of the wet with no
apophysis but just wanted to learn from
them you talked about one way having
them tell you but they use their
anthropological observational skills
which is another way and they found that
in those families the mothers didn't
wash the little crabs and shrimp that
are in the rice paddies out of the rice
before they cooked it so they were the
only kids in the community who were
getting protein in what was otherwise a
completely rice diet then they just
generalized that to the rest of the
community they taught the observation to
the others and they began to really
influence the nutritional status of all
of the children in the community not the
experts not even with knowledge did they
do that when the mothers were
interviewed they didn't really think
they were doing it for protein so all of
these ideas about observing the people
observing the users listening to the
crowd it's very hard we are trained to
be experts and the more well-educated we
are the more expert we are and so how do
you pull back from that expert model
when you're in that service mode and
really learn from the bottom up is kind
of unlearning some of the skills that
we've been taught and that we're
reinforced for having right yeah right